it's game six it's day six for the 2021
feed a world chess championship what
will the world champion do with his
third chance with the white pieces
he's not recalling he's he's studying
he's studying i like that and that's
important because
magnus caught him off guard he's trying
to figure out this position and just
because he didn't take the pawn and he
didn't develop doesn't mean that the
rest of the game is easy for him like
from the way he's acting
his body language and the fact that he
was playing very rapidly and now he's
stopping to think it looks like 96 was a
bit of a surprise
but i don't understand how it can be a
surprise
i don't know the way he's played this
game so far this really has been the
most impressive game jan has played
[Music]
magnus moves the queen up
game on ladies and gentlemen we have
action in game six not bishop before
what did they have in mind it was
fishing before was such an intentional
move i'm like
i'm kind of puzzled jan is trying to
keep this confusing for magnus with
these moves wait what just happened e4
knight f4 oh nicely fine no this is this
could be trian is blowing this position
here with no time now well like queen
before it will look 94 because if you
take the knight you lose the bishop
magnus carlsen has reached time control
jan napomishi has one more move to make
or he loses on time
queen b3
oh my gosh
[Music]
beyond is defending this end game well
honest defending is saying him
incredibly well i i think that this is
frankly if jan holds this it might be as
telling in regards to what we'll be
talking about in the world championships
anything else because this is the test
we have broken history here in the 2021
world chess championship because the
move rook to d2
officially makes this game
the longest game in world chess
championship history
[Music]
black has to be careful this is going to
be so hard for jan to hold because this
is he's just going to keep pushing this
[Music]
i think that's just winning because you
can't you can no longer check that king
anymore
[Music]
i expect yonda panmashi
to throw in the towel in this position
that's the way it is as i said it
shouldn't be easy in a world
championship match you have to um to try
for every uh
every chance no matter how how small it
is
[Music]
you